for more on the developments surrounding
president Trump we turn to Phillip bump
national correspondent for the
Washington Post Phillip good morning as
we said the Post reporting this morning
that Jared Kushner wanted a secret
communications channel with the Kremlin
York Times reporting that the Kushner
camp is saying that that was to open up
a dialogue about Syria this all makes
sense I mean lots of things make sense
today that wouldn't have made sense two
years ago I mean this is is an extremely
unusual move certainly the the Post
reporting suggests that Kushner in this
conversation with ambassador his lyac
suggested among other possibilities that
perhaps they might be able to use
facilities at the Russian embassy in
Washington which you know prompts this
very bizarre idea of Kushner walking
into the Russian embassy without somehow
attracting attention the American
authorities the real question here is
why they would make this request part of
the overarching question here is why the
incoming administration was so
distrustful of the administration is
already in place of the government
intelligence agencies and I think that's
a question that the FBI is trying to
figure out a lament is one of the
reporters on this story told CBS n
yesterday that this sort of fits a
pattern within the Trump administration
which is denial down play and that
there's always subsequent revelation
Reuters is reporting that there are
several other contacts at Jared Kushner
made with Sergey kis lyac that have been
undisclosed what more can we expect and
how do you think this informs the
ongoing investigations well it's very
hard to say what else we can expect I
mean obviously there are lots of things
that are being investigated and being
revealed all the time we're seeing this
pattern over the course of the past
several weeks and I think the real
question here is how the Trump
administration can move forward with
this cloud hanging over of the rush
investigation which all indications are
that Trump wants to move past this as
rapidly as possible but they keep doing
these things like these things keep
coming out about about you know things
that weren't reported and the
administration is not doing good job do
you think this informs Jared Kushner
security clearance to begin with yeah I
mean I think there are valid questions
about how much pressure Congress is
going to start putting on the
administration to get Jared Kushner
further away from the ministry I mean
obviously dear Christians in a very
unique place he is not only a senior
adviser president he is a relative of
the president yet as
the reasons he's so trusted and it makes
this a very particularly tricky issue
for the president the president was
hoping this foreign trip would distract
from this other news right as he had any
success on that front do you think well
he's had some success I mean he you know
there are certainly headlines about what
he's been doing overseas not all those
headlines have been glowing either but I
mean it really is just over the course
of the past two weeks we've seen all
these revelations starting probably with
the Post report on Monday of last week
about the fact that he had revealed his
classified information in conversation
with Russians I it's hard to get past
that without there being a full
investigation in America understanding
really what happened and unfortunately
for a president Trump investigations
like that are very slow when I was still
at the front end of it Philip the
foreign trip would seem to be a point at
which the White House it hoped to pivot
right to the offense and yet they come
back to these Russia revelations they're
also coming back to a Congressional
Budget Office score on the Republican
plan but it was passed in the house to
repeal the Affordable Care Act and
replace it with the American Health Care
Act which would leave 23 million
Americans without health insurance how
much is that an issue for this White
House this week I'm not sure it's a huge
issue for the White House this week in
part because the White House has not
been terribly hands-on with any policy
stuff and they got involved the tail end
of the AHCA one is being fought in the
house trying to put pressure on
Republicans try and get them to actually
switch their votes right now it looks
like all the action on that health care
bill is in the Senate itself I'm not
sure that Donald Trump wants to weigh in
very heavily at this point because it's
extremely tricky they're trying to get
this passed through this in it with only
50 vote with a 50 vote margin which
requires very specific rules for them to
be able to do that that combined with
public pressure from the outside based
on that 23 million uninsured
it's movie very hard for them to do that
I'm not sure Donald Trump wants to
quickly fill up a lot of reports of
staff shakeups in the White House what
are you hear one of the things we're
hearing is potentially to campaign
staffers Corey Lewandowski and David
bossy coming back into the White House
they're trying to set up apparently
according to Reuters this internal
communications team led by Bannon and
Kushner which i think is an unusual
choice given that they are part of the
communications problem Phillip Baum
thanks very much for being with us I'm
going